[Music]
it knows it's morality to be imperfect
because it is affected by the sense
nature and nature opposed to it which in
part adulterate morality itself as such
and in part give rise to a host of
duties by which in concrete cases of
real action it is embarrassed for each
case is the contents of many moral
relations just as an object of
perception in general is a thing of many
properties and since the specific Duty
is a purpose it has a content and its
content is part of the purpose and
morality is not pure this latter
therefore has its reality and another
being this reality however means nothing
else then that the being of morality
here is both intrinsic and explicit
explicit that is it is the morality of a
conscious being and intrinsic that is it
has an existence and a reality in that
first imperfect consciousness morality
is not realized there it is the in
itself or merely implicit being in the
sense of a mere thought being for it is
associated with nature and sense with
the reality of being and consciousness
which constitutes its content and nature
and sense are morally nothing in the
second consciousness morality exists as
perfect and not as an unrealized thought
thing but this perfection consists
precisely in morality having reality in
a consciousness as well as a free
reality in existence in general in being
something not empty but fulfilled full
of content that is the perfection of
morality is placed in the fact that what
has just been characterized as morally
nothing is present in it and intrinsic
to it on the one hand it is supposed to
have validity simply and solely as the
unreal thought thing of pure abstraction
and then again equally to have no
validity in that mode its truth is
supposed to consist in its being opposed
to reality and to be entirely free and
empty of it and then again to consist in
its being reality
we've now reached paragraph 630 the
penultimate paragraph in the section
decembe Lance or duplicity and what we
see Hegel doing here in this paragraph
is reintroducing on the side of the
perfect moral being or the holy will
whatever it is that we're projecting
beyond ourselves reintroducing a kind of
agency and even personality here he's
talking in terms of consciousness but
that's what's going along with it
because he talks about this as something
that's free introducing this into what
he had just previously revealed to us as
a unconscious would move us loss
abstraction so you might say well what's
going on here didn't Hegel just show us
that we we've gone through all these
dialectical explorations of the moral
consciousness and these this on this
side this on this side and in every case
we have these two thoughts that were
unable to bring together into some sort
of genuine synthetic concept because if
but instead we have a force telling a
representation for that is also if we
want to play on words a fair Stelling a
decembe once yes he did in fact do that
but now we're leading into the next
section which is about conscious
conscience the beautiful soul evil and
its forgiveness and so we're going to
have a centering on the moral person
having gone through this transformation
and by this point in the phenomenology a
transformation like this or if you want
to use the term that Hegel actually does
employ so often a sublation and out
fable a transformation that incorporates
that's something that we've seen happen
over and over again by now you should
expect that whatever impasse we reached
is going to be surpassed so he tells us
here that it what is it the moral
consciousness
in fact the moral consciousness you
could say is overarching both of these
sides now and the moral consciousness he
says knows it's morality to be imperfect
why because it is as we've talked about
so much here affected by what what is
being translated by Miller as sense
nature it's really the same terms inally
kite so you could just say sense or
sensibility or the sense faculty or all
that goes with being a sensuous being
and nature not who were opposed to it
opposed to morality right which he says
in part adulterate morality itself as
such and then they also give rise to a
host of specific duties a whole you know
coterie or you could say a myriad of
different duties that we have and here
Hegel doesn't just talk about duties as
such he talks about relations or
relationships but Zhi hung ways in which
we are connected with somebody else or
something else perhaps even an
abstraction like a promise that we we
have made so he says that we have a host
of duties which in concrete cases of
real action it is embarrassed by and why
is it embarrassed by these well as we've
seen already
none of these duties is by itself pure
duty hein afflict right each one of them
is an bazan Duras a specific duty that
pertains just to this particular case or
perhaps to cases of this sort but not to
everybody and yet they are duty and
we're finding ourselves unable to bring
them all under one single unified
workable concept so he says that in each
case we have the conch recen s--
the bringing together the growing
together of many moral relations
specific moral relations just as an
object of perception notice the analogy
that he's giving here is in general a
thing of many properties so think back
to the section the thing and its
properties which came right after the
very first section in what you might
call the epistemological beginnings of
consciousness right we had sent
certainty and then we had the thing and
its relations and then after that the
very complicated force the understanding
well the thing in its relations the
thing has all of these connections with
with the thing in its properties has all
of these connections with consciousness
itself so he says here we go just as an
object of perception is a thing of many
properties since the specific Duty the
the specific obligation is a purpose and
end a goal at Zak in German it has a
content it has an in halt there is
something there we could say well it's
about this here's how we do this sort of
thing that's how we learn our duties in
real life isn't it we don't learn them
by somebody handing us a book of cut and
saying read the second critique that'll
straighten you out
just just fine no we we say well this is
your duty today and here's what you're
supposed to do and oh you screwed that
up what you should have done is this and
we go on from there that's how we learn
these things and that's still where
we're rooted for the most part in trying
to explore the dynamics of morality so
he goes on and he says because this
content this in halt what it contains is
part of the purpose part of the end part
of the goal what it would be in order to
be fulfilled
it is not perfect and here if we were
looking at the the you know the German
language and thinking about it in some
what we could say Aristotelian terms we
would see a lot of things jumping out at
us in order to be perfect
you know the German for that is full
that innit and it's very similar to the
word that we use in in Greek to denote
perfect as well in in English we often
think of perfect as like lacking any
flaws and we have forgotten the more
active sense of perfection perfection
being that is getting something closer
and closer and closer to what its
fullness would be it's it's full right
full ended its final end it's being
brought to fruition as we say which is
almost a better translation a you know
fruition eyes dry then perfect and the
very fact that we have an end and that
our duty is aiming at an end means that
in a certain sense it should be perfect
right if we fulfill the duty completely
we satisfy that end and the end is made
real it's made actual but Hegel's saying
well no it's it's not entirely so he
says the latter this is the morality
therefore has its reality and another
being and we've gone through what this
other being looks like now here he
pauses when he says this reality means
nothing else then that the being of
morality and again the translation is a
little bit misleading here because
Miller chooses to use that the terms
intrinsic and explicit rather than just
using the you know more straightforward
in and for itself it is the morality of
a conscious being for itself a being
that actually relates itself to itself
and it is intrinsic and here he says it
has an existence and a reality now we've
been using this term reality or
actuality quite a lot throughout the
entire phenomenology and especially in
this section the entire spirit section
we've talked a lot about that I don't
need
go into that any further that veer click
I so it is making morality veer click
write existence is design here he's not
talking about a visa nan essence or a
being in some sense which could be an
abstract being here he's talking about
design actually being out there in the
world when we use this term existence
you know the X is often overlooked
what's the difference between existence
and being we don't have to go too far
into the metaphysics there there's a lot
of discussion of that in medieval
philosophy right but here's one thing
that you can say X Easter day means to
like stand out to be there as we say for
design so that's worth thinking about
for it for just a moment so he goes on
and he says in that first imperfect
consciousness morality is not realized
it's not brought to its fruition it's
not made completely actual so he says
there it's the in itself or merely
implicit being in the sense of being a
mere thought being and when we saw this
with the perfect holy will that doesn't
really exist that we can aspire towards
and maybe take is sort of an end point
for guidance we aim at that but it
doesn't really exist in it and it's a
projection coming out of ourselves Hegel
goes on further and he says there it's
the in itself merely implicit being in
the sense of mere thought being why
because it's associated with nature and
sense with the reality of being in
consciousness which constitutes as
content and nature and sense are morally
nothing insofar as we reduce morality we
completely natural eyes that you might
say Hegel would say we lose sight of
what morality is really about and this
is an important thing in in the
development there's an important
realization in the development of moral
consciousness now what about the other
side so he says in the second
consciousness and what we've projected
ourselves morality exists as perfect as
brought to fruition as fulfilled as
entirely what it's supposed to be and
not as an unrealized thought thing but
what does this perfection mean Hegel
says what does perfection of this sort
require he says well it consists
precisely in morality having noticed two
things you're saying here having reality
having Vere clea Kyte actuality in a
consciousness not by itself not as an
ideal not as something purely abstract
in a consciousness and you could really
say without a consciousness there is no
morality period at any point we we
project this idea of a morality like
something we could talk about in a book
or you know again create a video about
and have lots of words about but unless
it exists for a consciousness there is
no morality there morality is something
that is you might say part of the fabric
of consciousness human consciousness not
necessarily a consciousness per se but
human consciousness certainly so he goes
on and he says it has reality and a
consciousness as well as a free reality
this is very important it has the
possibility of doing otherwise again
that can't be that holy will that we
talked about before that always does the
right thing almost like a robot or a god
it's got to be a somebody like us who
actually has to struggle so he says an
existence in general being something not
empty but fulfilled full of content so
he says this means the perfection of
morality is placed in the fact that just
what has been characterized as morally
nothing you know what is morally nothing
sense and nature is present in it and
intrinsic to it is essential to it
which says on the one hand it's supposed
to have validity simply and solely as
this unreal thought thing of pure
abstraction which we talked about in the
previous paragraphs and then have no
validity in that mode its truth is
supposed to consistent it's being
opposed to reality and to be entirely
free and empty of it and then again to
consist in it being reality so we have
this again a dualism where we're not
able to bring both sides together and we
still don't completely know what
morality would be for us
the syncretism of these contrary
which is set forth at length in the
moral view of the world collapses
internally since the distinction on
which it rests the distinction between
what must be thought and postulated and
yet is at the same time not essential
becomes a distinction which no longer
exists even in words what finally is
posited as diverse both as a nothing and
also as a reality as one and the very
same thing that is existence and reality
and what is supposed to be absolute only
as the beyond of real being and
consciousness and yet equally to be
absolute only in them and so as a beyond
to be nothing this absolute is pure duty
and the knowledge of duty as essence the
consciousness which makes this
distinction that is no distinction which
asserts that actual existence has no
validity and at the same time that it is
real that pure morality is both truly
essential and also devoid of essence
such a consciousness expresses in one in
the same breath the thoughts which have
previously separated and itself
proclaims that it is not in earnest
about this determination and separation
of the moments of self and in itself for
intrinsic being but that on the contrary
what it asserts is having absolute being
outside of consciousness it really keeps
enclosed within the notes itself of self
consciousness and that what it asserts
to have absolute being in thought or to
be absolutely intrinsic being it for
that very reason takes to be something
that has no truth consciousness comes to
see that the placing a part of these
moments is a displacing of them add
assemblance and that it would be
hypocrisy if nevertheless it were to
keep them separate
but as moral pure self consciousness it
flees from this to parent disparity
between the way it thinks of these
moments and of its own essential nature
flees from this untruth which asserts
that to be true which it holds to be
untrue flees from this with abhorrence
back into itself it is a pure conscience
which rejects with scorn such a moral
idea of the world it is in its own self
the simple spirit that certain of itself
acts conscientiously regardless of such
ideas and in this immediacy possess
it's truth well however this world of
dissembling siz nothing else but the
development of moral self-consciousness
in its moments and hence is its reality
it's essential nature by retreating into
itself will not become anything
different its retreat into itself means
rather that consciousness has realized
that it's truth is a pretended truth it
would always have to be giving out this
pretended truth as its truth for would
have to express and present itself as an
objective idea but would be aware that
all this is merely ad assemblance it
would therefore be in fact hypocrisy and
the scornful rejection of that decembe
ones would be itself the first
expression of hypocrisy
paragraph 631 brings this section
dissembling sir duplicity first a lung
to a close this is the second-to-last
subsection of this massive spirit
portion of the work and we are now ready
to go into the new discussion of
conscience and the beautiful soul and
evil and its forgiveness that will bring
morality to its full conclusion within
the Hegelian dialectic and this is very
important because we're getting closer
and closer and closer not just to the
end of this section but to the end of
this work and so we're getting closer to
a concrete understanding spirit or
consciousness having developed over time
through human beings struggling to make
sense out of things that in this case
it's the moral consciousness which is
not completely finished but we've gone
through an important stage so here egle
talks about syncretism right and when we
see this term it often comes up within a
religious context where what we're
thinking about is blending different
religions together taking a ritual of
one religion and placing it within the
framework of another religion finding
some ways to make them you know connect
up with each other doing some
comparative work and what we're doing
here is somewhat like that except it's
not religions that we're looking at it's
rather we might say world perspectives
well belt on Shaolin right where we are
looking at a moral view of the world and
how we can assimilate it to all the
other things that matter to us and he
says that we have a syncretism of these
contradictions one of the problems with
syncretism is that you're taking things
that are in fact contradictory or at
least appear to be contradictory and
you're trying to say no no they can all
be brought together in one full
perspective that that
make sense out of all of them and what
we see here is yes we do in fact make
sense out of all of these dichotomies
and distinctions that we've been
exploring here but we make sense of it
precisely by saying what we were doing
was actually mixed up what we were
engaging with was verging on being as
Hegel is going to call it here
a type of hypocricy and then we have to
think about where are we gonna go after
this so he says the syncretism is set
forth in the moral view of the world it
collapses internally and she's
discussing how this collapse were flight
as he's going to call it a little bit
later on in this section in this
paragraph how does that that happen it
collapses internally why the distinction
on which it rests the distinction
between the most what must be thought
and postulated on the one hand what
consciousness has to somehow have going
on at least in in you know its
imagination or its hopes and dreams and
at the same time what is not essential
what is not real what is not actual says
this becomes a distinction which no
longer exists even in words that's a
strong statement the distinction we
could say well it's a merely verbal
distinction Hegel here is saying even
that distinction you quit even talking
about it that's an advanced sometimes
silence about things is the result not
of not knowing but it's saying well
we've already done that and it didn't
work so he says what is finally posited
as diverse both as a nothing and is also
a reality is one in the very same thing
that is existence and reality what is
supposed to be absolute only as the
beyond of real being unconsciousness the
ideally perfect holy will that always
fulfills moral
right that recognizes pure duty we come
to the point where we see that he says
is equally to be absolute only in them
and so as a beyond to be nothing we're
dealing here with a dialectic that gets
to the very root of the metaphysical
distinction between the absolute and
nothing or being and nothingness and
showing us that in some respect at least
in this issue they're not radically
different from each other so he goes on
and he says that the absolute is pure
duty and the knowledge of duty as
essence so the consciousness the moral
consciousness the human being who makes
this distinction that is no distinction
which asserts that actual existence has
no validity and at the same time it is
real that pure morality is both truly
essential and also devoid of essence
we're running out of contradictions here
right now kind of beyond merely
distinctions we have real contradictions
as we've been talking about in the
previous paragraphs
such a consciousness he says expresses
in one in the same breath the thoughts
which have previously separated and here
we get to the duplicity or add
assemblance right the fair Stella why he
says it's showing that it's not an
earnest it's not being honest with
itself and others about this
determination and separation of the
moments of what self and in itself it's
making all sorts of very interesting
distinctions but these distinctions
ultimately are breaking down none of
them are able to support the weight you
might say or to rise to the heights if
you want a different metaphor of
morality morality in a certain sense
escapes our attempts to conceptualize it
and by conceptualize I don't mean to
just simply form a concept in the sense
of have an idea of it or say some words
about it but to have what Hegel would
call a concept a bigger if a living
dynamic grasp of the totality of these
things in relation to each other how
they function instead what we have is a
kind of corrosion going on and he says
on the contrary what it asserts is
having absolute being outside of
consciousness it really keeps enclosed
within the self of self-consciousness as
I've been saying throughout many of
these paragraphs the the Beyond and this
is a typical Hegelian move that beyond
in which the being in itself the holy
will the perfect morality the anything
else that you want to put in there is
superlative it's a projection on the
part of consciousness it's just as much
of projection as it was way back when we
were looking at the unhappy
consciousness which saw itself is
nothing and the eternal as everything
whatever is fully moral in this case is
something belonging to that imperfect
moral self-consciousness which projects
it beyond and uses it to judge itself so
he says what it asserts to have the
absolute being in thought or to be
absolutely intrinsic being it for that
very reason takes to be something that
has no truth and notice that Hegel uses
the term truth var height here something
that he's not used through most of this
section
he says consciousness comes to see the
placing apart the outside on - Stalin
the setting in in in different places or
or setting one over here and then
pulling the other one away from it and
saying you belong over here this outside
under Stalin right out of each other
setting is placing a part of the two
moments that are being distinguished
from each other is really a
first alone a decembe once or duplicity
and Miller has a very nice way of adding
a little bit here he says that
consciousness comes to see the placing
apart is a displacing of them ADA
semblance the displacing into some was
translating the same term fair Stella
right so he says it would be hypocrisy
if they were to keep them separate well
this is in advance is it not it would be
hypocrisy if it were to keep them
separate and pretend like well this is
this is you know what we have is
morality instead it has to go further
and realize how things are and admit it
so he says as moral self-consciousness
it flees from this disparity between the
way of thinks of these moments and its
own essential nature it flees is a
beautiful line it flees from this
untruth which asserts that to be true
which it holds to be untrue what is the
essence of hypocrisy it is pretending
that something untrue is in fact true
it's sort of parasitical upon the truth
so the person who you know we take you
know traditional portrayal of the
hypocrite the person who well that's
thinking about morality right condemns
the immorality of their neighbors while
engaging in the very same thing
themselves there is a truth there in the
condemnation they shouldn't behave that
way
they shouldn't say have loud parties
late at night keeping everybody up but
then you're you know in your apartment
having an equally loud party and you're
just unhappy because you weren't invited
to that other party right then you're a
hypocrite and there is a truth there but
it's a truth that convicts everybody
instead fleeing from hypocrisy would
mean saying wow I'm a terrible neighbor
myself I got to knock this crap off
instead of worrying about whether
they're having a loud party first I got
to get my own appetites under control
and then after a while I'll go over and
knock
Durand said hey it's 3:00 in the morning
maybe you should tone it down a little
bit in this case we're talking about
something much broader I just used that
as this specific example so he says this
moral self-consciousness
flees from the untruth flees from this
with abhorrence back into itself so how
does it flee Hagel tells us it is a pure
conscience which rejects with scorn such
a moral ideal of the world it is in its
own self the simple spirit that certain
of itself notice it is get insight
certainty of itself acts conscientiously
regardless of what ideas instead of
trying to make sense of all this it says
damn and I know what the right thing to
do is I'm gonna fulfill my duties and if
I can't make sense out of all of us if
these distinctions that I introduced are
really just gumming the works up I have
to go back into myself and be a good
person so he goes on and he says in this
immediacy it possesses its truth so then
he says while this world of dissemble
ins is nothing else but the development
of moral self-consciousness in its
moments and hence is its reality it's
essential nature by retreating into
itself will not become anything
different so what we have here is again
a solution we are incorporating and
stripping away and reducing and moving
beyond right this is what Alf hey bong
consists in that's why we're moving to
another shape of consciousness so he
goes on and he says it's retreat into
itself means consciousness has realized
that it's truth is a pretended truth
it's truth it's truth that it's
conscious of is a pretended truth there
is still still truth out there but the
truth is that it's a liar that it is a
hypocrite that it it has to become
something greater than what it currently
is so
says it would have to it would always
have to be giving out this pretended
truth as its truth for it would have to
express and present itself as an
objective idea but it would be aware
that this is merely ad assemblance you
know we've seen this before haven't we
in the discussion earlier in spirit with
the culture section and the person who
becomes conscious of how much of this is
all just BS and nevertheless it has to
be lived up to in some way and so we
talk the talk and we play the game all
the while knowing that there has to be
something more something better
something truer than that so he goes on
and he says it would therefore be in
fact hypocrisy and the scornful
rejection of that decembe lense would be
itself the first expression of that
hypocrisy we are placed in a situation
similar to that which led to a kind of
madness and ear to them right a
wandering on the part of the person of
culture that then led us to something
further with faith and pure insight now
we have a different transition to make
to this you know conscience and at least
the attempt to have a beautiful soul so
that's where we're going next